that's his stance do not prosecute trump  there's not enough evidence number one  how in the [ __ ]  how in the [ __ ] does jeffrey tubin know  if there's enough evidence to prosecute  trump yet or not for anything  for anything there's plenty  investigations that are very close to  him and his allies  that give that give way  to possibly  possibly him committing federal crimes  state crimes tax crimes election crimes  who knows what crimes  we have several investigations that are  tied close to trump  i mean just to name a few number one of  them  is his his company  his company his own personal company  that he owns and he runs the trump  organization is indicted  in the state of new york under the  manhattan d.a who has his tax returns  they have them congress is trying to get  them but they have them that grand jury  has those [ __ ]